hi everyone thank you all for
watching this talk so i'm going to talk
about reach 221 games
this is joint work with mark weatherman
and subascot
so before we talk about what reached 201
games
let me give you some background about
what this talk is all about
and yeah so this other point of this
talk is the pcp theorem
and in order to state that let me first
introduce the label cover problem
so an instance of the electrical problem
consists
of a bipartite graph g
and two alphabets sigma l and sigma
are one for each side each of them being
finite
and finally a constraint for each one of
the edges of the graph
and a constraint is simply a collection
of pairs
of alphabet impulses that are considered
satisfying and the goal in level cover
is to assign vertices from l
symbols from sigma l and vertices from
our symbols from
sigma so as to satisfy as many of the
constraints
as possible
so there are many problems that can be
written in the language of label cover
for example max cut max tosat
toolin and the list is long
good so what do we know about level
cover well
using label cover we can phrase the pcb
theorem
this theorem says that there exists
delta less than one
strictly less than one such that if i
give you a label color instance
psi and i tell you that either you can
satisfy all of its constraints
or we can satisfy it was delta fraction
of its constraints
then it's np hard for you to distribute
between
these two cases it's important for you
to tell which one of these cases
holds well
that's a very nice theory but if you
want to prove hardness of approximation
results
oftentimes you need something much
stronger than this
theorem so what can you strengthen
well there are two obvious things that
you can try to
improve first of all you can try to
improve the soundness
namely instead of just saying that delta
is strictly smaller than one
you can hope to say that delta is maybe
even close to zero
and indeed such statements are known and
you can either achieve them but
what but by what is called parallel
repetition
or directly by using a
sub-constant or pcbs
so this talk is not about this type of
improvements but rather
another part of another type of
improvement
which asks for a better structure from
the constraints
so note that in level cover the
structure of the constraints could be
arbitrary
we didn't really say anything just
some relation between sigma and sigma
so you can hope to make it more
restrictive and hopefully it's
it can be useful
good so what is the best structure that
one can hope for
so this is in this work so what is the
structure that one can offer
so this is what i call the ultimate
structure
this is what is known as uni games so
what are uni games
well a unique game is a label cover
instance
that satisfies more properties more
precisely
the two alphabets are the same
and each one of the constraints is a
one-to-one map
for example maybe the alphabet
sigma l is just a field and then the
constraints could be
for example linear equations in two
variables
say a minus b equals one
good so so this is a very strict
structure right this is the best you can
hope for
and we don't know whether these problems
are hard but
we believe that they are or more
precisely caught conjectured
that they have a harder this is the
so-called
minigames conjecture it states that
the for all that location is on for
sufficiently large alphabet
if i give you a unique games instance
it's npr for you to tell me
whether it's almost fully satisfiable
or at most data satisfactory
so i want to like make one remark here
note that here instead of the one that
we had in level cover we had here one
minus delta
and this is inevitable because if you
have a unique game
that is satisfiable then it's easy to
solve it so this is really the best you
can hope for
so this is the reason this conductor is
stated this way
well okay so this is the best structure
we can hope for
so why should you study it
one reason is that if you are able to
prove that
this problem is np hard then
now you would prove that many other
problems are np-hardened
namely uh once you assume minigames
uh you can show harness approximation
results for many many problems
oftentimes they are tight for example
for ferrous cover max cutting
for general csps
so this is certainly one proof of the
conjunction
but of course this is the conjecture so
by definition this is a con
it's conjecture we don't know if it's
two or not so
we hope that it's true but we don't know
how to prove it
okay so uh so let's maybe relax our
structure requirement let's maybe settle
for something a bit
less respective than one to one in the
hope that maybe we can prove it
so what is the least restrictive the
most restrictive structure that is
not one to one well this is what is
called two to one games
again a 2-1 game is simply a
specific type of flavor cover in which
the alphabet
sigma is twice as large a sigma arrow
and each one of the constraints is a two
to one
map for example
maybe sigma l is a field sigma
consists of all the quadratic residues
and each constraint is a
quadratic equation such as a squared is
equal to b
so this is one example of two to one
game
so for this problem in the same paper
code also conjectured
that this problem is hard but now you
don't need this one minus delta anymore
and simply conjunction that for all that
are greater than zero
for sufficiently large alphabet and
given a two to one games instance it's
npr to tell
whether it is satisfiable or at most
data satisfiable
well so we cannot prove the conjecture
as stated but we can prove something
very close to it
so this is a little one game's theorem
so it started forever epsilon for every
delta greater than zero
for salvation in large alphabet and it's
impaired to distinguish between
almost satisfied with two to one games
instances and at most
data satisfiable and two to one games
instances
so this is good because this is a pawn
it's provable
it's very restrictive type of structure
so we're happy
but somehow unfortunately this
difference between two to one and one to
one
really seems to make a lot of difference
and as far as applications are concerned
so there are less applications there are
some but they are certainly less and
oftentimes this type of filling is not
enough to prove
tight in approximability results
so the main question that we asked
ourselves in this work is
are there any intermediate problems
between two to one games
and unique games
so i'll say shortly the answer is yes
and we're going to spend the next couple
of slides
in order to define these problems
and okay so
now we are going to define a new
parameter for
problems which is called weakness and
this is
what will define our
intermediate so recall that
two to one game is simply a elevator
instance
where each constraint is hit one map
now we are going to define partitions
so what do i mean by that well let's fix
some
vertex u on the left side
and let's consider each one of the
neighbors of you
so i claim that each label v of
u defines the partition of sigma l into
sets of size
2. and why is that well
look at all alphabet elements
of sigma r and look at all the
pre-images of them
according to the two-to-one map between
u and v
so for each sigma there are two images
so this collection of two images
is a partition of sigma l into sets of
size two
okay so this is simply the partition
that you and
define and now that we defined
this partition we can look at the
distribution of our partitions
that is associated with u
so what do i mean by that well for each
vertex 0 consider the distribution of
the partitions
p u v where you sample v uniformly among
the neighbors of u
and the rightness parameter that we care
about
sort of measures how random looking this
partition
looks like among all partitions of sigma
l
into sets of size 2.
okay so this is the rough intuition but
now let's make it
a bit more precise so here's the
definition
for an integer r in a 2-1 game
we say that the 2-1 game is always rich
if for each vertex you
on the left if you look at
this distribution of a quotation that is
associated with it
this distribution is always independent
in the sense that if i tell you r minus
one pairs
in it the alpha would still look
uniform
and in case r is the maximum that can be
in case i is the size of the alphabet of
the right side
we say that the game is fully rich
and often we'll just omit the fully and
just say that it is rich
good so this is the main definition that
we care about and now that we have that
i can tell you
our conjectures which are new
conjectures that sort of
make a way between 2-1 games and unique
games
so our first conjecture is asserts that
reach 2-1 games
remain hard with imperfect completeness
namely for every epsilon greater than
zero
for sufficiently large alphabet if i
give you
a fully rich two-to-one game it's
impaired for you to tell me
whether it's almost satisfiable or it is
at most
epsilon satisfied
but note that now that we're looking at
2-1 games
there is no reason to believe that
satisfiable instances
are easy anymore unlike unique games so
it makes sense to consider
an even stronger conjecture which i call
here conjecture 2
which asserts that forever epsilon
greater than zero
for sufficiently alphabet if i give you
a fully reached tone then it's npr for
you to tell me whether it's fully
at most epsilon satisf fiber
great so now that we have presented
these two conjectures
there are several questions that come to
mind
here are two of them first of all
how do the how do these conjectures
relate
to the unique games conjecture are they
weaker they need
are they stronger it may be equivalent
maybe
incomparable that's one question
and the second question is okay so why
would you study these problems
what is good in them and i hope that
i'll convince you that these problems
are interesting
so here's our main result our main
result asserts that conjecture 1
is in fact equivalent to dna games
convection
that is ugc holds
if and only if conjecture 1 holds
so let's uh take a moment to make some
polarizers
so it means that if you look at all
reach
221 games where r is
not follow then these problems are
intermediate problems between
uc and between two to one games
so you can think about it as sort of a
ladder between
two end games and unique games and the
higher
in the latter you go the closer you get
with me games
so it makes sense that in order to make
further progress on ugc
would have to develop some tools that
show hardness for rich games
but from a deeper different perspective
another way to look at this theorem is
as saying that conjecture 2 namely the
conjecture
with perfect competence is in fact
strictly stronger
than udc
this is very interesting because one
feature of unigames which is very
limiting is that it has an imperfect
completeness
and therefore we cannot apply it all the
time
for example if you want to prove harness
for coloring problems
but conjunction 2 doesn't suffer from
this
lack of perfect completeness so
so we can hope to use that
so i'm not going to say too many words
about the proof i'm going to
show you sort of the main lemma
in the next slide but i do want to say
that
the point of this theorem is not really
the reduction
the reduction is a very standard it is
the reduction
from the paper of codkin and mozilla and
donal and the novelty here
is in the soundness analysis
so many times in pcb reductions
you have to use some sort of analytical
machinery sometimes
it is in the form of the
hypercontractive inequality
sometimes it's invariance principle but
really always you have to use something
and in our work we do use some
analytical
tool but we use something a bit exotic
namely we're using a hyper-contractive
inequality on the symmetry group
which was just recently established
so how does this enter the picture well
i don't have time to
you know tell you the whole proof but
here is
the main lemma
so to tell you the main lemma i need to
make one quick definition
so suppose i have a bounded function f
from 0 1 to 2n to 0 1
and i have some code in it then the
influence of coordinate i
on f is the expected square difference
where you sample x uniformly from the
cube
and you look at the difference between f
of x and f
of the the point that is x except that
it's different in the i-coordinate
good so now one more definition
so if i have a function from 0 1 to the
20
to 0 1 and i have some 2 1 map
pi from 2 n to n then i can define
the projection of f along pi
the projection of f hello pi is a
function that takes
n bits and outputs some numbers between
zero and one
and it's simply defined as f at point x
it is simply defined as f of y
where y is the perimeter of x
namely for each coordinate y i is equal
to x
at the coordinate pi of i
good so now that we have definition of
inferences and production
we can state our main lemma and there
are several
parameters in it but really the idea
here is that
if you have a function that has low
degree
and has all of its influences being
smaller
and you take a random projection of it
then the function
will still have small influences
more precisely for all tau greater than
0
and d there exists some tau prime
such that if you have a function of
degree at most d
all of these influences are at one star
prime
then if you choose a projection pi
uniformly
with high probability the maximum
influence of the projected function
will be smaller than tau
so this is the main lemma it's i think
that is interesting kind of by its own
because it's a
kind of a natural analytical question
and if you're a bit familiar with pcb
reductions you can maybe
imagine how it enters the picture but
otherwise
i agree that it's a bit unclear but
trust me this is
the main thing that you have to do
yeah and as i said in order to prove
this lemma
what you really need to do is do some
analysis on the symmetrical
sn
good so let me finish the talk by some
discussion and
open problems
so first of all we looked at the notion
of
average in 2-1 games
and though i didn't say that if you look
at r equals one
this is exactly the same as the 2-1
games
instances that we currently know that
are harder
and we know that this type of instances
imply that unit games is hard between
half and epsilon
our main theorem with this work is to
say that if you have full richness
then you get the whole thing about uni
games you get unique
between one and epsilon and epsilon
and an interesting question here is what
do you get
from richness with r that is more than
one say two or
three or hundred would you get an
improvement of a uni gains between half
an
epsilon so i think that this is an
interesting question
it would be good to know
the second question is what can we do
with
conjecture 2 what can we do with
hardness of 2-1 games
with perfect completeness
so can we use uh h201 games with perfect
completeness in order to establish
harness results
for satisfiable instances say for csps
so this is something that i think that
is possible and is promising
and in fact uh currently we have a work
in progress that
does some preliminary steps along this
direction
and together with brother man caught the
elephants
and finally in a maybe more
abstract sense so we know that
in order to prove harness for two-to-one
games or
for r equals one what you will use
is the so-called gaussian graph so this
is the main object that
you need to study there and it's
interesting to ask
whether there is some combinatorial
gadget that would plausibly imply
hardness of average game with
r better than one so
even if if it's only a candidate it
would be very interesting to know
and a thing that if we come up with
something like that then
it will lead to further progress on all
of this direction
so i hope that you enjoy this talk and
thank you very much